أوكرانيا المجد لأوكرانيا
حشد القوات والسفن الروسية في البر
والبحر
وأماكن قليلة في أوكرانيا أكثر
عرضة للخطر من
هنا مدينة خاركيف على بعد 30 ميلاً من
الحدود الروسية إنها مدينة يبلغ عدد سكانها حوالي
مليون ونصف شخص يتحدث 75 منهم على الأقل
اللغة الروسية  كلغة أم ، فإن
مظاهرات كهذه مهمة
لأن هذه المدينة
قد تكون واحدة من أوائل المدن التي
تتعرض للهجوم في حالة الغزو
[الموسيقى]
فلاديمير زيلينسكي ، حذرنا الرئيس
كثيرًا ويقول المسؤولون الأمريكيون
إن فلاديمير بوتين يمكنه الأمر
بشن هجوم  في أي وقت
كل يوم
أحاول أن أكون هادئًا وأحاول متابعة روتيني اليومي
ولكني أحاول
أن أفكر جيدًا أين
وثائقي
أه أين الطعام أين أمي هل
لدي ما يكفي من المال
في مدينة تم تحديدها على أنها
هدف روسي محتمل من قبل
الرئيس الأوكراني ، هناك محاولات
للمضي قدمًا كالمعتاد
ولكن بالنسبة للكثيرين ، هذا هو الوضع الطبيعي الجديد الذي
لا
أريد الفرار ،
لذلك أحتاج إلى حماية
أوكرانيا  لقد وسعت جيشها
لكنها بعيدة جدًا عن روسيا في
القوة العسكرية ،
لذا فهي تأخذ هذه الدبابات المحطمة
من طراز T64 من الستينيات
وتعيد بنائها من الهيكل المعدني
للاندفاع إلى الخطوط الأمامية
مثلما تحاول أوكرانيا بناء
ديمقراطية والدفاع عنها في  المشهد
يسكنه الاتحاد السوفيتي الذي يهيمن عليه
الروس سام كيلي سي إن إن خاركيف